-The select House committee
investigating
Donald Trump's attempted coup
on January 6th
held its second hearing today,
and it was just as damning
as the first, with multiple
Trump aides and advisers
on tape confirming
that there was no evidence
for Trump's stolen election lies
and that they had told
Trump repeatedly
that there was no evidence
for those lies.
Oh, also, Rudy Giuliani
was wasted on election night.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today's hearing was no less a
blockbuster than the first one,
which is saying a lot, given
how many bombshells there were
in the first hearing last week.
Today, the committee laid out
in painstaking detail
the degree to which virtually
everyone around Trump,
from his campaign manager
to his attorney general
to his own family,
knew that there was
no evidence of election fraud
and told Trump there was
no evidence of fraud.
-They wasted a whole month
on these claims
on the Dominion voting machines,
and they were idiotic claims.
I told them that it was --
it was crazy stuff
and they were wasting their time
on that.
All the early claims
that I understood
were completely bogus and silly,
and usually based on
complete misinformation.
-Told him flat out
that much of the information
he's getting is false
and/or just not supported
by the evidence.
We look at the allegations,
but they don't pan out.
-So, this wild claim
is thrown out,
which, you know,
on its face didn't seem,
you know, realistic
or possible to me.
-I thought
the Dominion stuff was...
I never saw any evidence
whatsoever
to sustain those allegations.
What they were proposing,
I thought was nuts.
The theory was also
completely nuts, right?
I mean, it was a combination
of the Italians, the Germans.
I mean, different things
had been floating around
as to who was involved,
Hugo Chávez
and the Venezuelans.
-I told him that the stuff that
his people were shoveling out
to the public were --
was bullshit.
I mean that the claims of fraud
were bullshit.
-Of course it was
all bull[bleep].
It's like Trump asked
for a story
that explained why he lost
and his team said,
"How much time do we have
to come up with it?"
And he said, "Three seconds!"
And they said,
"Uh, uh, a dead
Venezuelan dictator
teamed with, um,
an election software company
and the governments of Italy,
Germany, and China
to stuff fraudulent ballots
into suitcases
and shopping carts?"
[As Trump] Oh, that's good.
You guys are worth every penny.
[Normal voice] Actually -- uh,
actually, sir, you don't pay us.
[As Trump] Exactly.
[Normal voice] Everyone around
Trump knew it was bull[bleep]
and told Trump
it was bull[bleep]
over and over
and over again.
But Trump went ahead and
declared the election stolen
anyway and spent months
spreading that lie,
despite hearing repeatedly
from his closest aides
and advisers that what
he was saying was insane.
And documenting that Trump knew
it was all bull[bleep]
is important for establishing
his frame of mind.
He obviously had
criminal intent.
I know this is obvious,
but still, it's important
to establish that he wasn't
just, like, innocently
investigating credible
allegations of fraud.
He was actively trying
to overturn an election
he knew he did not win,
and engaged
in many potentially
criminal activities to do it,
including fomenting
a violent attack on the Capitol.
In fact, Trump's campaign
manager, Bill Stepien,
even said in one deposition
that he and other Trump aides
who knew there wasn't fraud
had been divided into a separate
group from all the crazy people,
and the non-crazy people
even had an informal name.
-I didn't mind being
categorized.
There were two groups of them.
We called them kind of my team
and Rudy's team.
I didn't mind
being characterized
as being part of Team Normal,
as reporters kind of started
to do around that point in time.
-That's right, they were known
as Team Normal.
Now, I could tell you
the specific names of the people
who were supposedly
on Team Normal.
Or I could just tell you that
none of them look like this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[As Giuliani] Hey, I'm here
for Team Normal tryouts.
[Normal voice] Actually,
I'm sorry, Team Normal's full.
[As Giuliani] Be honest.
Was it my eyes?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[Normal voice] Also -- Also,
in regards to Stepien,
I'd argue
that despite his resistance
to Trump's fraud claims,
he was still just as complicit
as anyone else,
given that he was managing
Trump's campaign
even while Trump
was preemptively claiming
the election would be rigged,
and never once spoke out
to warn the public
about how dangerous Trump was.
And yet, for some reason, the
photo they used of him all day
made him look kick-ass.
Look at my man
So-Called Life-in' it
Claire Danes style.
God, it' so cool that
she grew up to be in the CIA.
And whatever happened
to that other guy?
Aah!
Fun fact -- they put him
on Team Normal before Rudy.
Either way, Trump obviously
decided to go with Rudy
over Team Normal.
Now, early in her
opening statement,
Congresswoman Liz Cheney
teased that the hearing
would touch upon Rudy's role
in the attempted coup
when she said this.
-You will also hear testimony
that President Trump
rejected the advice
of his campaign experts
on election night
and instead followed
the course recommended
by an apparently inebriated
Rudy Giuliani
to just claim he won and insist
that the vote counting stop,
to falsely claim
everything was fraudulent.
-I mean, that is brutal.
It's embarrassing to have
a member of Congress announce
on live television
that you were visibly drunk.
I mean, I've been visibly drunk
on TV before,
but it's for entertainment.
Never once during any of
my Day Drinking episodes
have I ever said to my guest,
"Hey, you wanna do a coup?"
[ Laughter ]
And let me make something
perfectly clear.
If Rihanna had suggested it,
I would have been down
at the Capitol in a heartbeat.
[ Laughter ]
Now, when Cheney said
Rudy was inebriated,
I thought, "Damn,
that's embarrassing,
But I guess
that's the end of that."
What I could have never
imagined in my wildest dreams
was that it was just a tease
for what was coming up,
because it turns out
a significant portion
of the hearing,
bolstered by witness testimony,
focused on
former Mayor Giuliani,
an attorney to the president
of the United States,
being blitzed
out of his [bleep] mind.
-Were you in
the White House residence
during the sort of --
past midnight
into the early morning hours
of November 4th?
-Yes. Oh, sure.
It went over beyond midnight.
Yes.
-Do you remember Rudy Giuliani
being at the White House
on election night
and into the early hours
the next morning?
-I do.
-What do you remember
about when he came?
-Um...
[ Clears throat ]
He...
He was, um...
They were...
I had heard that
he was upstairs, you know,
in that aforementioned
reception area.
And, um...
he was looking
to talk to the president.
And it was suggested
instead that he come talk
to several of us
down off the Map Room.
-Was there anyone
in that conversation
who, in your observation,
had had too much to drink?
-Um, like Mayor Giuliani.
-Tell me more about that.
What was your observation
about his potential intoxication
during that -- that discussion
about what the president
should say
when he addressed the nation
on election night?
-The mayor was definitely
intoxicated, but I do not know
his level of intoxication
when he spoke
with the president, for example.
-It's so funny to me
how in all these deposition,
Trump aides are all
hemming and hawing,
pausing and taking their time
to use the most precise
legal language possible
because they're under oath.
But then, as soon
as someone asks,
"Was anyone drunk
at the White House?"
they all immediately buzz in
like the overeager uncle
on "Family Feud."
"Rudy! It was Rudy!"
[ Laughter ]
In fact, if "Who was drunk
at the White House?"
was a question on "Family Feud,"
the top five answers
would all be the same.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I love the follow-up
where the lawyer says,
"Tell me more about that."
I wish I could have seen
the rest of that deposition.
"And how did you know
Rudy was drunk?"
"Well, I saw him holding
an empty bottle of Scotch
and hitting on a portrait
of Dolley Madison."
[As Giuliani]
Well, hello, young lady!
Now, before we go any further,
you have a legal obligation
to tell me
if you're my cousin.
[ Laughter ]
Fool me twice!
[Normal voice] So,
as the committee established,
Trump had a choice between
Team Normal and Team Rudy,
and obviously
he chose Team Rudy.
In fact, Trump's son-in-law,
Jared Kushner,
who looked in every clip
like he had just smelled
one of Rudy's Scotch farts,
said at one point that he tried
to warn Trump about Rudy,
although you could tell Kushner
was definitely walking
on eggshells
when he answered the question.
-Did you ever share,
Mr. Kushner,
your view of Mr. Giuliani?
Did you ever share
your perspective about him
with the president?
-Um...
I-I guess...
[ Sighs ]
Uh...yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Tell me what you said.
-Basically, "Not the approach
I would take if I was you."
-Okay. And how did he react?
How did President Trump react
when you shared
that view with him?
-Oh, he said, you know,
"I have confidence in Rudy."
-That was a very long pause.
You could tell Kushner did not
want to answer the question.
I'm shocked he didn't break out
into a song called
"We Don't Talk About Rudy."
That's definitely the length
of the pause you take
when someone asks you
about a friend
who was super drunk at a party,
especially a friend
you invited.
"Hey, uh, you know
your friend Kyle?"
"Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs ]
"Yeeeeah."
"He just did a cannonball
in the pool
with all his clothes on
and told everyone
if they didn't do
a Jell-O shot with him,
he'd have them arrested."
"Yeah, but so what?"
"Well, it's a kid's
birthday party."
So, today's hearing
was laser-focused
on disproving the big lie
and showing the public
that everyone around Trump,
except for the drunk
and/or crazy people,
thought the fraud claims
were insane
and told Trump
those claims were insane.
And here's a key point.
A lot of people
are watching these hearings.
So proving that Trump
was both full of [bleep]
and knew he was full of [bleep]
is important
because a big question going
into these hearings last week
was whether people
would watch.
Republicans and right-wing media
personalities, for example,
were invested heavily in
the idea that no one would watch
because they had better things
to do, but they were wrong.
And audience of at least
20 million people
watched the first
prime-time hearing,
in the ballpark
of television events
like a big
"Sunday Night Football" game
or the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade.
And I'm not surprised
the hearing
got Thanksgiving Parade ratings
since so many
of Trump's inner circle
look like they could be
balloons.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, look, kid,
it's the Mike Lindell balloon!
Oh, stop crying. It's not him.
It's just a balloon.
Oh, wait. Okay.
I actually do think
it actually might be him."
[As Lindell]
"Yeah, it's me, alright!
They just tied some strings
to me
and filled me up with da air!"
[Normal voice]
So, the first hearing
actually ended up
scoring big in the ratings,
even though one channel
conspicuously decided
not to air it,
which was, of course, Fox News.
Fox News stuck with
its normal prime-time shows.
Not just that, they also didn't
show commercials
for the entire two hours
that the hearing was on,
because they didn't want their
viewers to change the channel
and see the hearing
on a different network.
-They didn't take any commercial
breaks for the entire two hours
when the hearing
was taking place.
The reason you would not
take a commercial break
is because you do not want
your viewers to have a chance
to click over to another channel
to see what's going on.
You want to keep them
with you the whole time.
Last night, Fox News eliminated
two hours of commercial breaks,
at the cost of
I don't know how much money,
thousands of dollars,
all to keep their viewers' eyes
away from the truth
that was airing on every other
news network in the country.
-Think about that.
They were so desperate
to keep their viewers
from seeing the hearing
that they cost themselves money
by not airing commercials.
You know how many Acorn
Stairlifts they could have sold?
Though I don't think
that was necessary.
If you've ever been in a home
where they watch Fox News,
you know they're not big
on flipping around.
I'm pretty sure they just buy
the TV, put it on Fox,
and then bury the remote
in the backyard.
But still,
just think about that.
Fox went an entire two hours
without airing
one of their usual commercials
for some dumb scam product
aimed solely at old people
like gold coins,
tactical sunglasses,
commemorative plates with
Ronald Reagan's face on them,
or a MAGA teddy bear
with Donald Trump's voice.
"I love my MAGA teddy bear!
You just push his belly and he
says the most adorable things."
-Then they did dumps.
They call 'em dumps.
Big, massive dumps.
[ Laughter ]
-It's also not surprising
that Fox would want
to keep its audience
from watching the hearing
because in addition
to providing damning evidence
that Trump knew the election
had not been stolen
and that he orchestrated
a criminal plot
to overthrow the government,
the hearing was also
deeply embarrassing
for the Trump family.
For example,
the committee played video
of Trump's daughter Ivanka
saying she accepted
Attorney General
Bill Barr's assessment
that there was
no widespread fraud
and that the election
had not been stolen,
meaning she disagreed with her
father's stolen election lies.
-Many of President Trump's
White House staff
also recognized that
the evidence did not support
the claims
President Trump was making.
This is the president's daughter
commenting
on Bill Barr's statement
that the department found
no fraud sufficient
to overturn the election.
-How did that affect your
perspective about the election
when Attorney General Barr
made that statement?
-It affected my perspective.
I respect Attorney General Barr.
So I...
accepted what he was saying.
-Oh, you did? That's weird.
I don't remember you mentioning
any of that in the two months
after the election,
when your father planned a coup
and fomented a mob
of armed insurrectionists
and werewolves
to ransack the Capitol
like a Black Friday sale
at a Bass Pro Shop.
Ivanka, just like Barr
and Stepien and all the rest,
could have easily
spoken up at the time,
but instead she just
quietly faded away,
hoping no one would notice.
She basically tried to do
the Homer Simpson GIF.
[ Laughter ]
Also, this is just a side note,
but I do love how they always
use the [bleep] cameras
for these depositions.
Ivanka Trump
was the most glamorous member
of the Trump family,
and now she looks like me
doing my show during lockdown.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Piece...
Real quick piece of advice,
Vank --
Don't read the YouTube comments.
Because people will have notes.
But the most predictable
part of Ivanka saying
she agreed with Barr
was that her own father
threw her under the bus
by responding the next day
on his social media site,
where he essentially said
she had no idea
what she was talking about.
-Trump is downplaying
his daughter's involvement,
writing on his
Truth Social platform,
"Ivanka Trump
was not involved
in looking at
or studying election results.
She had long since checked out
and was, in my opinion,
only trying to be respectful
to Bill Barr
and his position
as attorney general.
He sucked."
[ Laughter ]
-Even with his family
turning on him
and millions of people watching
nationally televised hearings
describing his
mental fragility,
Trump still has
a way with words.
[As Trump] "Mr. Barr was
derelict in his duties."
No, that's too wordy.
Let me say, let me think,
let me think.
"When the moment called
for courage,
Mr. Barr failed to answer."
No, that's not quite right.
Oh, it's on the tip
of my tongue.
"He sucked."
That's it!
[ Laughter ]
These hearings have
so far been powerful,
effective, and well-produced.
They've painstakingly proven
that Trump and the people
around him
knew what they were saying
was a brazen and dangerous lie,
and that the riot was not
just some impulsive incident.
It was part of a detailed plan
orchestrated by Donald Trump
to stage a coup
and overturn the election.
Trump's team tried
to tell him the truth,
but he refused
to accept it.
Meanwhile, Rudy saw
a drop of Scotch
left at the bottom
of the bottle
and was so desperate
to get it out...
-He sucked.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Audience cheering ]
-I'll accept it.
I'll accept it.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.